We give our best people,
for values, for rights, for freedom,
just for the desire to be equal, the same as you,
the same as everyone.
We give our best people,
the strongest, bravest, most incredible Ukrainians.
I am talking today and now about my fellow citizens,
the citizens of Ukraine,
who defend values and freedom
at the cost of their lives.
I am glad that we have united all of you,
all the countries of the European Union,
but I did not know this would be the price.
And this is a tragedy for me, for each Ukrainian,
a tragedy for our country.
The price is extremely high,
thousands of people were killed.
No one will break us, we are strong.
We are Ukrainians.
You know, we have a desire for our children to live.
Yesterday, 16 children died.
Once again, President Putin will say that
this is some sort of operation,
and "we are hitting the military infrastructure."
And now, we are fighting for survival,
and this is our greatest motivation.
But we are also fighting to become
equal members of Europe.
I believe that today we are showing everyone that we are.
With us, the European Union will definitely be stronger.
Without you, Ukraine will be alone.
We have proved our strength.
We have proved that we are at least the same as you.
Prove that you are with us.
Prove that you are not letting us go.
Prove that you are truly European.
And then life will overcome death,
and light will overcome darkness.
Glory to Ukraine!